[Music]
wherever i go in this country certainly
and i actually tested it overseas in
bulgaria i always i consistently get a
laugh for
the following line which is not
which is the truth it's not a joke
i have
christian and i both have an uncle named
dick long
and well dick his name is dick yes his
last name is long right what did i say
dick long
yeah it's not one name his name isn't
dick long long that that'd be
that you'd get a bigger laugh
yeah that'd be pretty gang as the kids
say gangsta kids say that now well
adults say too cooler adults okay that's
what i meant
not like nerdy 43 year olds
but uh have you ever heard the term
downstroke no oh it's a great term it's
like in punk music the first chord is a
downstroke and so there's instead of
saying like that's punk that's punk rock
it's down stroke it's like well that's
uh it's really like leaning into
something i'm gonna start using that oh
yeah you know i think what's punk rock
is
that's the whole story oh yeah let's not
push the story that's a [ __ ]
downstroke yeah right speaking of punk
rock life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life is short i am
your um gangsta host whoa
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
this feels like an appropriation uh oh
gangster
you're not a gangster either what are
you talking about
it's hard not to appropriate some
culture
you're we're done you're abortion you're
more
you're more buggsy siegel than
you are
tupac yeah
yes
uh you're closer to bugsy i don't know i
don't know uh
wait a minute i mean you're so far from
both of them
no physically of course i'm closer to
bugsy seagull i'm only picturing warren
beatty i don't know you're not bugsy
siegel looks pretty have you ever seen a
picture of him yeah he's you look at
nothing like him i i bet two people in
color you have the same skin color you
think my features are closer to tupac
tupac was very handsome i i know i wish
i looked more like tupac i'd rather look
more like tupac than warren beatty in
fact wow well warren beatty has um i
don't know warren beatty's
yeah he's pretty we talk about how
good-looking guys are way too much on
the show who cares cares all right well
we're also talking about dicks not dicks
but our uncle dick yeah he's a dick and
by the way he's not a dick he's he's
really great he's great and he's um all
of our uncles are very funny we're
blessed to have funny we do also side
note uncle dick dick long long comma
dick our uncle dick is
our teammate on family feud rich rich
long for people who saw that that's his
dad yes and rich was very funny on the
show yeah you so you can see rich is
very funny in life yes yeah he but he he
had a few like real zingers on the show
he had a few things that got cut out
yeah i know i know um dick just came of
age in a time where that name dick
was very common it it wasn't every tom
dick and harry that was the expression
there was a very that's how common it
was yeah it's part of an expression that
means common
uh refers to a commonality but i think
even when he was named the word dick
still referred to male genitalia do you
think i don't know when that became oh
maybe i'm wrong how can i just assumed i
don't know how the two would coexist how
did that how did a penis i've thought i
thought about become a dick i i have
thought about that way too often i don't
know well we should try to figure should
research that a little bit shorties sure
it's interesting because it it couldn't
have been uh as common it couldn't have
been a penis name back then or at least
a common penis name uh here's another
fact about um uncle dick is that i know
he enjoys a nice cold beer yes
but i've also
never to my memory seen him drunk
no he's a very moderate person as is our
other uncle uncle tim who's also very
tall
he brews his own beer very funny i've
never seen him drunk either there was
also a movie called fun with dick and
jane that's right fun with dick and jane
maybe the great adult title would just
remove the aunt jane
so uncle dick is not a drunk uncle no to
us but some uncles are drunk i'm sure he
has been drunk i'm sure we should talk
to mother but i don't want to shame him
for it he the point is he doesn't have
an issue with a substance abuse here's
the larger point why are we talking
about drunk uncles i'll tell you why
because our guest today is
the very funny bobby moynihan who's
maybe best known character uh is drawn
kunkel he's on snl yes that's right um
that was a key part of the introduction
that i missed i think most people would
connect it because they know bobby
moynihan from snl man bobby is one of
those um
performers who just commits a hundred
percent and
there's no better example of that than
his drawing clinical character who uh we
talk about today i i was really curious
about the origin of that
character i always am about where
you know characters come from but um you
like a good committer i do i do and he
commits with the best of them he sure
does he was on snl for nine years i
believe yes and we talk about this too
but he's so good speaking of committed
performances he is so good in this movie
um
uh sisters i think with the amy poehler
movie and i should know the name if i'm
going to reference it uh where he plays
this
he plays an unfunny guy a guy who thinks
he's funny and he steals the movie
and to do that from amy poehler and tina
fey is a real feat um and then he gets
he does like a ton of cocaine later at
this part anyway it's it's just one i
it's one of the funniest performances
i've ever seen ever it's he's so good in
it but um he's always so good and he
played on snl he played a lot of like
really over the top characters that were
felt like real like
a little bit like reminds me a little
bit of cecily strong yes um friend of
the show yeah in that they found such
specific specificity
in their characters but and they like
did big things but it all felt so real
he always felt very real to me yeah
likewise you don't both have to think
bobby moynihan's commitment to his
characters is real he now has a uh a new
show an animated show that he created
yes tarzan called loafy
about a um a manatee who sells pot and
side note this might sell spot god i saw
an old man you don't sound like gangsta
no i don't
it is so hard for me i for someone who
like really
see uses a lot of weed i almost said
uses a lot of weed it's impossible for
me to talk about that without sounding
uncool i know we've talked about that
but it's it it remains true yes
uh well anyway do you know what else
remains true what my excitement about
our guest today
i would like to hear this i i would too
even though i was there for it i want to
re-listen and i hope that you all want
to just listen for the first time to my
catch-up with the very funny the
committed hilarious bobby moynihan
life could be a dream sweetheart
this episode of life is short is brought
to you in part by audible gather the
family for story time magic with audible
listen to imaginative heartwarming and
festive stories original podcasts and
more brought to life by incredible
performers enjoy brand new audible
originals like the cinnamon bear
and exclusives like the christmas pig by
jk rowling fire up modern classics like
harry potter and the sorcerer's stone
and so many more all-time favorites
now's the time to listen together go to
audible.com
listen together
that's audible.com
listen together listen now only from
audible
hello hello
[Music]
bobby where are you uh i'm in a friend's
barn no i'm in my i'm in my house um
oh my god i really i would have believed
you
uh it's very white there yes it's a very
white right now yeah it's a pure white
room we get our furniture like next week
oh oh nice oh how exciting uh you would
uh
first of all i am so sorry
i i'm glad i get to look at you when i
do this now because uh
oh man you you
thank you for we can't bailed on you and
um it was uh i loved what you said you
were like oh i'm just like playing with
my dog
my daughter it's just more time to play
with her which sounds awesome yes it was
it was great
yeah how old is she now four do you just
do characters now for her is it just
like playing
i'm just imagining how fun you must be
it's been a lot of playing i'm a pl it's
been a lot of playing i still play i
play more than she does uh but um
yeah i don't
we're
it's a lot of like dada your rainbow
dash from little pony
she has you oh she does the casting she
does the blocking she does everything
and then and i do it and i do it uh no
matter what
i bet the bar
has been set so high for with somebody
like you because you're so gifted at
characters and likes what you do for a
living
and she's going to be around other kids
and like their parents are gonna you
know it's always so weird it's it's a
mess already in in that sense in the
sense of like
yes she'll go to like like well before
the pandemic when we would go to like my
gym or like one of those like places
where you jump around and like they have
toys and stuff like
it's boring because like that
my garage looks like looks like a
children's
toys oh my god
because you're also i mean i you've
talked a lot about being feeling like
you were like a fan you were like a fan
of uh star wars all these
things
yeah i'm a fan of things
yeah
that's a terrible way to phrase that no
i am thank you oh yeah i think it's
actually a great way to put it so you
still have all that i mean i have a lot
of masters of the universe revelation
question oh oh right yeah oh we gotta
get into it well you're friends with all
those masters of the universe is that
kevin so kevin smith's doing the new
he-man uh i was just you know mentioning
my the nerdiest thing i knew about you
right right off the bat oh oh yeah well
it's pretty nerdy one although i wasn't
were you into that when you were a kid i
was i wasn't really he-man uh i was i
was sue i was very into human oh really
yeah
yeah yeah see because star wars felt
like it was the same time as star wars
and it felt like those two worlds
clashed to me for some reason i don't
know why i went right into transformers
from got it uh the the cartoons the
he-man the he-man the cartoons i i
actually i may have like found star wars
later kenner toys were like my
introduction to star yeah
do you remember seeing the movie because
we're about the same age do you remember
seeing
you're younger than me so you may have
missed empire strikes back there's no
way i'm younger than you there's no way
oh well i'm 44.
oh i'm 63.
nice oh okay yeah uh i'm i just turned
43. okay so you're we're about the same
so you just say i think i'm older i look
like i didn't look like a sweet boy but
you do it was always so funny that's
what i loved about seeing you playing
older people because you'd have this
like old hair like drawing uncles just
like gray hair but you had this kind of
like
there's nothing i love more my dream i
mean you should have seen me pandemic
bobby i was my dream is christopher
lloyd like just yes wild wild white on
camera just do whatever yeah
i remember seeing this maybe on
instagram that you had like a gandalf
fest you had like a wizardy beard yes i
had a very long beard for the for the
pandemic i went for it it was it was
glorious is it weird for your wife to
kiss a beard
i mean you want me to get her
no i'm just gonna
um she probably couldn't be honest in
front of you
we haven't kissed yet uh okay okay okay
done everything else i will let you know
um oh please fingers crossed faker's
crosstalk that's funny
14 years we've been together 14 years oh
man i'm rooting for you
you're going to love it it's uh i'm
hoping for 15. well i didn't know that
she was a broadway she was a theater
actor yeah yeah yeah and and is that how
you guys met uh scandalous we uh uh we
met the ucb she uh
she was in my improv class i was her
improv teacher but we didn't start
dating until afterwards
i was a good teacher
oh yeah
i did that as
as you stroke your beard
it's good for that i guess it's good to
yeah it's good to have like a move um
and you did i didn't realize you did ucb
for that long for i mean you were doing
it for quite so people always think as
did i that snl you know is your first
thing and you kind of come out of
nowhere and
um no no i was uh ucb 2000 i started
wow um
and i got snl 2008 i think oh wow man is
that just a natural you loved it since
you were a kid
uh yeah seth meyers when i got the show
the night i got the show i saw or maybe
it was like the weekend i got the show i
saw seth meyers and he said uh
congratulations uh you'll never talk
about anything else again for the rest
of your life and i was like i i remember
laughing at the time but it's it is it
is completely true
every conversation gets there it's
bonkers
even with friends i'm sure even with
like
p you run into people from
school or whatever people i mean you
must find the same thing but like
yeah you know it was funny i would find
more with like without close people it
was people going like how do i get
tickets like that's what
but uh but um yeah i imagine there are
two different versions now you even said
like what the time i i mean at the time
you laugh it off i'm sure but in
retrospect what would you say to that
bobby like like the you know the the
like the eager you're on snl and like
somebody says something like that with
you and there's there's like a degree of
cynicism in that
yeah i mean like one of i think one of
the hardest pills to swallow and like i
thought that that's terrible thing to
say i have a very amazing life i'm very
pleased and happy with it but with snl
like that that thing was like
the the thing for me that was confusing
with it was being told like well you
just act like you're a star just act
like you got it you know like that's it
you did it like now just act that way
and i was even more terrified than
before but it was like i think that's
what i would tell myself is like
after i got the job like then i should
have just had fun and enjoyed it because
like everything after that was just
instead of being in my head so much oh
for so many years of just like oh god am
i gonna get fired am i gonna get fired
like i should have told myself even if i
do it doesn't matter i was on snl for
five seconds like i know but it's hard
it's easier said than done i guess when
you're in it everyone i know on that
show has a version of that oh everybody
has their journey i'm very happy very
pleased with where i am on the on this
side at this point well bobby three
years out
i bet um
you especially having a kid i mean like
that also must put throw everything into
into perspective you have a kid i know
you went through i i
certainly don't have to talk about it
but i know you went through a lot of
like personal
oh yeah tragedy during that time and
like you know soon after i murdered a
bunch of people you yes you murdered and
you got caught that's the bummer of it
all right that's the only thing i'm
upset about
[Laughter]
but you um
but you had said that keenan i just want
to like because this this struck me that
keenan was the one was the guy or at
least the guy that you knew well enough
that was um
that was just made for that was just
made for snl had the bandwidth for it
and and said something to you like you
know just let it
let everything roll off your back i i
really admire that
his
i think the angriest i ever saw keenan
at work in my nine years there which is
by the way not even half his time there
what how long has he been there he will
i think he j well he well he wants to
hit 20 he said nine i think he's been
there eight to 18 years tonight oh my
god
like that's knox man that's amazing it's
strange that's it he's been doing it his
whole life
yeah yeah yeah
yeah he was just like the angriest i
ever saw him was like a joke he didn't
like he was like really that we're gonna
do
like
that was like the most upset i ever saw
him that's amazing that's amazing that
that to me is like it's funny you
mentioned kevin smith and like i've been
and i also heard you say something like
off the cuff about having smoked too
much weed and you're not remembering
things um and i as you said that it was
like i don't remember i was saying are
you right
but i was struggling to remember things
myself and um
and every time i see keenan you know the
after show people are
going to those after parties there's
always like an air of um
there's still some nerves in the air
it's still like
well and also just socializing with
people like that in that capacity it's
like kind of
keenan has always been like
so [ __ ] chill like weirdly chill
well yeah i mean like he that i think
like it's just
if if there's any way to like
the key to life is keenan thompson is
just like simplify everything it's just
like ain't this isn't this nice we have
a job is it like
is it isn't it nice we have a family i'm
gonna go home to them when this job is
over yeah yeah i know how and it's just
like it's just and he's very good at
just
that and like he's but but also he's
become something very different since
like the moment i left like it was like
keenan went
like it's like like everything like he
all of a sudden he was on that show and
like you know
now it's a very different vibe at snl
like when i was there we were trying to
write sketches every week now it's like
ev you know they're also have their own
shows and they're on other shows and
they're like you know
it wasn't necessarily like that in my
that's true there weren't as many
certainly nearly as many platforms i
guess for that stuff now it's like um
when i first started andy was like
they're putting one of my sketches on
this thing called youtube and i was like
what the [ __ ] is youtube
that's like andy sandberg like that's
the one who told me what it was
is that wasn't the great day well you're
in the great day one
uh yeah i was in a car i mean that was
like my first year was like
i have a very distinct memory of my
first episode the uh the the one was
space olympics and uh i was i wasn't in
it and i remember watching it going like
that was amazing and then like it
dawning on me like i might be in that
like in one of those next week and like
i remember like
it's it's fanboy like like all over here
in space right you've described yourself
that way i was that way growing up i'm
like
same age we grew up i grew up dana
carvey and mike myers and all that um
we were in a sketch together yes yes
were we we both played like matthew
mcconaughey
yes that's right that's right um am i
crazy
no no it was a ghost sketch and i
remember um
god i had just the tiniest i mean maybe
it was heightened for me because i only
i got to do like you know how sometimes
when you just have like one or two lines
and something it's like oh that's the
worst stakes oh it's the scariest and
like stakes are so high and it's like
you have one line to do it well and so
yeah i had that one line and i think i
was just like
i think maybe two in my head about it
and it was an impression that i had done
a bunch and um i immediately felt like
oh i want to do it again oh that's yeah
and then have that feeling for the rest
of your life because you can't
that must be fun every week for nine
years yeah i don't know how i seriously
sometimes like i i kanan's just built
different like he just like you'd be
like your sketch is cut he was like cool
like
and you're just like all right
but bobby were i think he was just
better at handling it i think he just
had been in the business and he's just a
very good guy he's a good man well i
mean yeah you heard you mentioned i've
been doing this as well i recently got
into meditation and um
do you ever wish like god the tools that
you have now or the things that you're
cultivating
do you wish that you
had those while you were on the show i
mean oh a billion percent i i i
one person like during like a very like
chaotic
night at snl uh one person said did you
ever just think about getting therapy
and i remember being like are you [ __ ]
like like i i snapped like i triggered
like i went like are you crazy
like me
like i went like i went i went nuts
that's funny
i mean it's tragic but it's funny you
think i need therapy i was like it's
that's [ __ ] tight like it's like
like i went nuts i was like you're
blaming me you're not the institution of
saturday night like uh i wish i had gone
that night
that person was very very very right
yeah yeah well i that person whoopi
goldberg
that's what i thought i thought sounds
like a whoopee thing to do
but i do but lastly but of course
drawing kunkka must be the thing that
comes up the most
right in terms of saturn live yeah yeah
so probably yeah
and when i think of you i think of um
i think of like somebody who really
commits to things and drunk uncles an
example of that but i i think
specifically of the part you played in
sisters uh
which is to me one of the i think i may
have texted you about this i meant to i
was going to say that that that in in
all
in in all of this leading to this that
that text was like i think about it
often it was just a very
nice thing to do and a very kind like
that people don't normally do that and
it was wonderful and
i i still remember it to this day it was
yeah that was the coolest oh man and
also being a fan it's also just like in
that thing of you go like oh that's
right these
we we watch everyone else's stuff and
it's fun and it's wonderful oh
it is i was i was a fan of yours but
when i saw that i i i said it i i meant
to articulate it you're doing something
in that that is like on a level of i
think about like martin short i think
about guys who
um
really dana carvey like commit in um
with everything you you were i it was a
it was a brilliant uh it was real i mean
i really meant that i mean that that's
that's amazing martin short is like i
mean seeing seeing that man in person
was like oh
i i i can't i can't even like he was put
on this earth to entertain
somebody hit an on switch and i know
never turned it off thank god like but
also sweet like not that might sound
annoying you know i know there's in fact
like your character and sister is like
that's like the annoying
version of that
yeah and humorless version
but martin short is like is is he not
like i've heard that he's just the
nicest
in addition to being the most
entertaining it's it's it's that that
he's a he's a person like a like a
magical little sprite like when you
listen
put aside being like a super fan of snl
and all that stuff and being on the show
but like
to just be like walking down i was
walking down the hall one night and just
like
my i don't know if you've been at snl
that top floor like near the studio like
you you right where you go in the studio
you get there's a huge window where you
can see the entire studio yes and uh
uh
right right off to the side is my
dressing room door and like
it never gets lost on me i was turned in
the corner and i looked through the
studio door and i was just like oh man
this place i guess like holy christ like
just like literally having a moment of
just like i can't believe this and i
opened my dressing room door and
my dressing room and martin short
martin short just pops up out of my
couch like how dare you i just started
screaming
that's amazing immediately screaming at
me and scolding me and then like within
five seconds it's like i'm kidding sit
down sit down sit down and i'm just like
what is happening like that's was that
your first season no no i think that was
a little bit later it was like had to be
like one of the five timers club he was
using my he was using my dressing room
for something and my god
but it was just like that that
that stuff would happen that stuff you
turn a corner and like paul mccartney's
there and he's like you want pizza and
you're just like
yeah wow yeah i want to see paul
mccartney
does it begin to erode any like any kind
of like
celebrity weirdness that you have
because everyone has like
i i mean unless you're like keenan and
you grow up in it like but for the most
part people are have that weird
relationship with
celebrities and famous people but does
it start to demystify that a little bit
or does it enhance it
i remember like uh if it was like a
couple years in
jim carrey hosted and it's like
you start to get oh you start to get a
little numb you start to get like a
little numb with people and jimmy's like
who's this week yeah and or like
i
that's a whole nother story that was a
cool thing where it was like who's this
like i can i i think i can
i i have i'm comfortable saying this out
loud i was like who's this week adam
levine like all right yeah and then it
was like and then adam levine shows up
and you're like whoa this dude is
the best like this dude is like he was
super down to do everything like he was
so funny he's come back a couple times
like he's
you did it you did a digital short with
him right uh he's been in a couple
things that i wrote like he he came back
and
i wrote this thing with taran uh
called uh
a standoff where it was like me me taran
and jeremy renner were guys like
pointing guns at each other like in a
stand oh yeah and then the whole thing
was that jeremy renner had to go pick
his kid up from school and like we just
went through his day and like with guns
pointed but at one point we ran yeah at
one point we just run into adam levine
and he pulls out two guns too
and he just asks for directions but like
yeah he would like like i remember that
week being like meh but he like turned
out to be awesome and like i've spoken
to him a few times since the show's over
like and that
sort of stuff was insane
well but it probably reveals that like
you forget that everyone reveres snl the
way the way we probably did growing up
or for the most part especially
entertainers like that's been an
institution so long so i'm sure somebody
like adam levine is like thinks the way
similarly to the way i do or you do is
like yeah i want to do something on
there it's snl yeah or like sometimes
you go like oh this person's a musician
or something they're not going to be
great like i remember bruno mars like i
was like oh okay like i know i i know
bruno mars this will be fun he's he
seems he has a lot of energy and then
like he killed it like just killed him
i have a i have a memory of being in
that sketch where he was singing
in that sketch where he was doing like a
bunch of impressions and the audience
just being like
the place was literally rocky yeah like
yeah
that's
he does incredible impress yeah people
that like would surprise ariana grande i
remember seeing her in this incredible
impression they did like a similar
sketch yes yes they did like they
brought that sketch back with her and
did it like the same thing that he did
yeah
doesn't that make you feel like uh oh
[ __ ] you can do that too it's like i
thought that's that was what i did you
know
uh right yeah no i was never good at
impressions a singing or impression not
but not my bag i i i like to be um
yeah chubby chubby weird dudes
i've heard you say that but like i've
heard you do i think it's george lucas
i get lucky sometimes george lucas is
fun but like it's more like i just
happen to look exactly like him and same
thing with snooki and guy fieri i'm
vaguely italian
yeah but even guy fury like i don't know
i think i don't think you're giving
yourself enough credit there is um you
capture in essence to those people it's
similar to what dana carvey did which is
like oh yeah that's not exactly ross
perot but like that is ross bro that's
like
you've you've captured and committed to
an essence of them i i shouldn't be as
down on myself as i am but like when you
work with people like daryl hammond and
jay farrow and like right even cecily
like cecily's a very underrated like
like with her with her things tara and
kill him too like oh my god but like you
would walk up to kate and just be like
hey can you do this and she would go
like
yep i could do it and you're just like
son of a [ __ ]
i bet i've had one of my most
embarrassing moments like if like if
when i think back of snl was uh just
like they they said hey we wrote this
thing where you're playing rudy giuliani
and i remember just being like nope
not this week not this week no
oh really not gonna do it and they were
like you're playing rudy giuliani it's
easy it's easy just do it
and
just do the penguin it was like
i i would see like that's the thing like
like yeah that's the thing that's
exactly what i should have done but like
i i went like i i i was like hi i'm rudy
giuliani and like just like didn't give
a [ __ ] because i didn't want to i didn't
want to do because i knew like i was
like hey like how many people have done
an amazing rudy i think that's kate
ended up doing like i was just like no
way no i i yeah but i wish i had tried
or i wish i had just had fun like that
right right like taking a page out of
keenan's playbook and just like just
give you know your honest and i see that
would that kind of monday morning
quarterbacking would kill me because i
would do that i would i would i would be
afraid to commit because if you commit
it's you have to
it might you might fail you know well
there was just so much pressure and so
much like want
to like but i'm also but like but like i
was at ucb for 10 years getting ready
for saturn in their lives so here's my
suit salesman character
and then all of a sudden they're like
you have to audition for trump and i'm
like i don't want to play trump like oh
my god
[Music]
you look healthy and
you look less stressed i appreciate you
noticing do you know why well i you i
you had told me you were getting more
sleep i was but do you know why no do
you know how is it the plus cbd yes i
know i've been taking them too i love
these things and these things you pop
them before you go but they're delicious
first of all these gummies are fantastic
oh man you wake up feeling focused and
refreshed turns out they're formulated
by a team of medical experts and doctors
i've tried the calm gummies i've tried
the sleep gummies and
last night for the first time i tried
the reserve collection gummies which is
a life is short exclusive the reserve
collection is a specially curated blend
of full-spectrum cannabinoids that
celebrates our very first batch of plus
cbd oil they're rich in bold they're
reserved collection gummies with 25
milligrams of cbd and 2.5 milligrams of
thcs these are your mothers no sleep
you got you got some fun stuff in there
actually they might be your mother's
sleep companies they should be good for
mom sure elicit feelings of calm and
relief when intense support is needed i
took one last night
and
man intense support was neat do they
work yeah you were really calm and
relieved seeming visit
pluscbdoil.com and enter promo code long
for 40
off your
order in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
[Music]
you talked about the feeling of not
like committing to something the
giuliani moment but like do you have
the opposite feeling when you then do
commit and it and it like it works like
something like drank uncle when you
when you when that's just like
a thing you're trying out and it and it
and it really kills
does it feel what does it feel like i
don't know what it is to be on an iconic
platform and just kill that the the
second time the second time i did
drunk uncle
i remember feeling like a little like
all right i hope this works because i
did it once and i hope it works again
and when they said drunk uncle and
people were like yeah like we're excited
like we remember this and i was like
it's
yeah what like and i remember that that
second drunk uncle being like
i was i was a little i had like
i had like 50 percent extra
like yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah there's i mean there's there's
hundreds of moments on snl that that i
play over and wish i could go back but i
i think i honestly think i'm in a you
know a much better place about it now
than ever
but uh i bet
it's is it now fun to look back is it
like is it
is it fun to pick out the moments of you
know to kind of reflect on you you had
mentioned jim carrey you're about to say
something about oh yeah well that that
was that was like you start to get numb
like i think that was like a year or two
in
and then all of a sudden it was like you
know the pitch meeting and it was like
uh you know ladies and gentlemen carrie
and jim carrey
when they said jim carrey he like stood
up and like started going like
like he won and he was just being very
jim carrey and i went like really big
like i just went like holy [ __ ]
like i just lost it like it was like my
entire like the moment i remember
sitting in the movie theater and seeing
him kick that box
in ace ventura and i remember being like
what am i like what is this movie like
what am i about yeah i remember like
being like
that first jim carrey week being like
slapped in the face with like oh yeah
this job is [ __ ] crazy
yeah it's funny taryn cited him
specifically too is like that was a
moment of
i can't believe we're playing in the
sandbox with this a guy like this one of
one of the coolest things i ever got to
see at snl two was that week was uh
seeing taran
hold his own with jim carrey in that
sketch where they're the robots
yeah and just being like man this [ __ ]
like this show is bonkers like me and
taran had a couple couple really good
years of like
complete
childhood fantasy sketches of like just
getting to play in these like universes
that we loved with like it it was an
amazing thing but like i i remember that
week too and that halloween sketch they
did they were great together you're also
similarly wired you have similar uh
there's a childlike and i mean that in
the best way there's a you're able to
mine in innocence like a real childhood
wonder a stupidity
yes i couldn't put my finger on it a
refusal to grow
yes arrested in development
uh
no but you you you both seem like you
have a joy that's why i miss you both on
that show because there was
whatever you were doing there always
seemed you did it um that's why it's
interesting to hear you talk about the
giuliani moment because my impression of
you is always that
has been that you really commit to
things you were you you're fearless
it was the last year it was my last year
on the show i was done like it was like
whenever they asked you to do an
impression or something i immediately
was like [ __ ] like
because they're like no one there there
was no one that you you were like i'm
comfortable like if if you you said
george lucas you happen to look like i
had to like
like everything i wanted to do people
were like
that's a little weird
like i would always
like i'm carrie fisher and they were
like yeah i don't know and i was like
i'm danny devito and they were like
that's a friend of lauren like it was
like
or like you know like i'm george lucas
and it was like yeah joy he knows lauren
too like it was
kathy bates i asked to play kathy bates
once and they were like nope like you're
kidding well that the four examples i
gave just happened to be all lauren's
friends those were terrible examples
yeah or good but i would be like could i
be pen gillette and they're like you're
wendy the snapple lady and i'm like that
right
[Laughter]
yeah
and who is your snl guy who is like your
who's your favorite probably like farley
phil hartman yeah bill murray obviously
you know dan aykroyd's like
the first year dan aykroyd just like
he's just he's like bill hader like he's
just like every single thing
there's just people who can do
everything like kristen and kristen and
kate and cecily to me those guys are
savants they're like yeah it's scary
yeah
mike myers like you know like i forget
how how influential mike myers was i
know i know and how different how the
hit the spectrum of characters that he
played too to go from like
simon like the little kid in the tub to
like sprockets like he was really
versatile
i loved him
was there a moment bobby when you would
hear the like the satin and bobby moyne
and don pardo announcing your voice was
there a moment where you like i'm s i
know there was a moment where you were
when you first heard it it was like holy
[ __ ] well the first one i burst into
tears like but i was waiting for it
because like i couldn't believe it yeah
it was nuts but it but it never got old
it never got away oh really that's what
i wanted the greatest one ever and he
has since passed he was the greatest in
his boot that he had
for hundreds of years
he had all of our names
written
in his handwriting spelled out
phonetically with like these weird
symbols like he had like it was it was a
lot
he just walked past me he didn't talk a
lot he walked past me and he just went
he had a cup of coffee in his head he
just went
bobby moynihan
such a fun name to say
not like that [ __ ] nightmare nassim
pedrod
and he just kept walking
and i guess he had a hard time with the
seems name but
and it was the greatest one of the
greatest moments of that's
being an snl fan i was like yeah oh
that's that's what i came here for
oh man that story i know the trials the
tribulations you must have had but
that's kind of what
uh how quickly did you tell him to seem
that story
i i was about to say i don't know if i
ever have i'm sure i have i'm sure i
have but like oh man oh the best
i had a one moment of like
like what it must have felt like in that
pressure cooker and like with
lauren i was dating drew drew was
hosting at the time and um
we had gone out a couple nights earlier
with and she's like i want you to meet
lauren and
er because she was like he does so many
good impressions he did he's so good at
impressions and and he and he said who
do you do you know and i just remember
freezing oh yeah and it was a casual oh
god who do you do to learn my i mean
every dinner table every single question
he has ever asked me in my life is the
hardest question i've ever had to answer
like he would be like how are you i'd be
like
why do you want to know
yeah yeah i know it's not casual i don't
want to just say fine because then i'm
the boring guy but but also there were
people there were people there who were
like lauren would be like how was your
weekend and they would be like great
what did you do and like
that was fine and that helped them and
that like you know i was not that person
ipad and nev and you never you were nine
years you never got to like no i i did i
i definitely have i think i have a great
relationship with lauren i could have
had a much ease i i held him on a
pedestal that i should have realized
was
he he understood on day one that i was a
giant fan of his and very thing
i should have i should have uh i i
should have understood i think yeah um
um but yeah he but i've spoke to him i
think more since i left you know than
any a lot of people there
oh wow that's cool he was wonderful yeah
he's the greatest i i feel very
comfortable now i would feel very
comfortable now emailing him because i
don't have his phone number
right you can email him and ask him his
number
so i it was last question about drawing
gold was he based on anyone was he based
on somebody that it felt very specific
it is that's what i thought i didn't
want to say that i thought it'd be
arrogant if i said are you doing me but
i always
i always
i thought
oh yeah no it's like do you know chris
gether yes yes
i used to do this bit for chris gethard
at ucb i
i didn't drink that much at one point
i don't drink at all
um but like uh
i would do this bit at the ucb like bar
mcmanus down the street from ucv
where i would just sit at the bar and
pretend to be hammered and just just
sing just constantly sing the song let
me clear my throat
but
no one no matter what no matter what
anybody said to me i wouldn't i would
just pretend i was crying very drunk
just going live
bro
i just like to just sing that song and i
don't know why like it was just a weird
[ __ ] thing i would do to make chris
kether laugh
that's really funny and then that
was like i think like when i got snl
they made us write down a bunch of names
of characters and like i didn't have
many and i wrote down i just wrote down
drunk uncle mike
i just wrote that down i just wrote down
like 20 names i was like i'll figure it
out later and
just in case like so at least i own it
and like jost was like hey i want to do
an update do you have anything and i
literally went to go look at that list
saw the name i saw the name drunk uncle
mike and i was like i don't know maybe
like a drunk uncle kind of thing like he
was like and he was like what do you
mean and then like jost was the one who
was like
oh that's hilarious like an uncle like
at like thanksgiving and like then we
like an hour later we wrote it we wrote
it in an hour and i never thought about
it i was like we'll never do that one
that one was stupid wow really just
because it was so simple because it was
so like off the cuff
i should have known better it it rolled
off our tongue to me it was more like
also another thing about jost is like
you walk into joe's office at literally
5 30 6 in the morning like while he's
like getting ready to like sit on the
couch and like put a blanket over him to
go to bed for a little bit and he'll be
like he'll be like you want to write
something and i'll be like yeah what
about a drunk uncle and you'll say four
jokes and he'll go
all right i'll see you at noon and then
at noon well that's not true at 1 30
he'll come back with like a fully
written sketch and you're just like yeah
no this is it and that's exactly what
happened
what wow and like so bright so quick i
remember the second we read it i was
like oh
i think we'll do that this week and then
like um now every time i pass that funko
funko pop of it i cry
yeah isn't that funny well yeah it's the
cool like that's like that that little
fan of me that little fanboy part of me
needs to
has grown up and moved on a little bit
which is nice
it was yeah but still but what is what
is that juggling act like when you
you have that the excitement still of
that and you still have like remnants of
the fan
in you that got to do that but then
there's the people yelling eh your drunk
uncle
how do you navigate those situations i
think i'm like coming out of a tail end
period right now where like i'm in a
really nice spot where like i haven't
had like almost any saturday night live
in my life other than like other than
like
seeing the new episodes as a fan
but like just watching them and then
moving on like as entertainment um after
snl it was just it was i got married had
a baby went through a bunch of stuff and
then like
now with pandemic stuff it's been a lot
of start and stops but like the best
part has just been going from
sleeping four hours a night for nine
years to
[Music]
doing that for like one year kind of but
like our daughter was a good sleeper so
it really wasn't that bad like so like
now like my hours are insane my hours
are like four in the morning to 8 p.m
and that's it like oh my god and i'm and
productive i imagine
i've been well that's another thing too
was realizing like i think the little
kid in me was like snl's over what the
hell do i do now but now it's like
yeah i have a bunch of stuff coming out
that i'm really excited about like i
can't wait for people to see stuff that
sounds that you've created you created
loafy um it's a cartoon but it's not one
that your daughter can watch it sounds
like incredible he's a man she's a
manatee
oh she's hitting it oh really
she's interested in the second episode
oh that's so funny i love when they get
real kids to do kid
me too i see a trey parker like a little
video of trey parker putting his kid and
stuff and it just makes me laugh oh
that's funny but does he do one of the
um they do those kids on uh the can the
um ike i think i can yeah oh that's
funny that makes sense uh why why it
sounds so funny um but i'm so curious
why a manatee
was just like a funny
they're funny uh it was literally that
it was literally why not um it was uh
my i i enjoy manatees i think they're
mean too
they they're hilarious they're they're
adorable beautiful and yeah uh yeah and
my wife adopted a manatee for me for one
year for like like how you could like
adopt a star like it's just like yeah
you just you don't really adopt a
manatee as much as you uh
pay for a pay for a piece of paper um
that says you do um
uh but that was it like i just enjoyed
manatees and always joked around that i
was gonna write a show
called loafy about our manatee but he
was how successful he was and he was a
very famous drug dealer and
uh
and then got a phone call i think it was
like imdb it was like like they were
like doing this show called oh god now
i'm forgetting the name of it is the one
that kevin hosted kevin smith hosted a
show uh i don't think so not that one no
um no no he he hosted a different one uh
it was about like projects that never
got made and you came on the show and
just told them about it and then like
they animated a little bit of it
and uh comedy central we went to comedy
central we were like we actually kind of
think this is funny and then they ended
up making a couple shorts oh that's cool
that's how fun and you get to do you
improvise a lot of it
uh that was the thing it feels
improvised i loved dr katz uh growing up
yeah right so originally the pitch
was
just
loafie's a manatee who can't leave his
tank he can't leave his tank and he
sells weed so no matter what if you want
to buy it you have to come to him and
that was literally just the whole joke
was dr cat so like we just for animation
we just didn't have to make people leave
they had to it was to sit in one spot
that's perfect but uh and it was just
gonna be that i mean i was just gonna do
a bunch of shorts uh of of like
different people coming to buy weed from
this manatee and talking
and it turned into something very
different like
comedy central was talking about making
we all tried to make it into a series so
it became like partly scripted but like
i feel like it was a little weird in the
end it was like half improvised half
scripted and we tried to mix the two but
like if i could do it over again i would
um i love it well now is it totally
scripted is it is it are you
is it that you wish it had you had stuck
to one or the other uh
yes i wish i had just done it completely
uh improvised with just that little
thing but i do but i do love my little
feet i love i love it oh i bet i'm doing
another one now with them with them same
people called lightning wolves about
thundercat stuff i heard you somewhere
else saying and i now i don't want to
ask um you were saying you were you had
a great zoom call i i loved this idea
that you
had like kind of a reunion with old
friends with like high school friends
and like friends you hadn't seen it was
so great where are you how do you know
all this and what uh this is from listen
to it it's from my
oh i mean i'm amazing yeah yeah
yeah no it was i really enjoyed it but i
um
now i'm just gonna wait when did i'm
just gonna rehash everything oh yeah i
didn't even tell my wife that this is a
mine you do a mayam bialik after show
pod
yeah it's that i think hers is called oh
my brother's gonna i do the show with my
brother and he's always like don't do
too much he hates when i like which is
what's happening now when i listen to
something and i just kind of rehash what
i've heard and say on other podcasts
[Music]
oh [ __ ] i'm doing it i'm doing it right
now
[Music]
[Music]
i have a series of lightning round
questions if you indulge do i do i win
actual cash
yeah it's uh it's we pay you eventually
it's not it's not real cash but it's
it means just donate it to
old people okay okay old drunkards
please um what is your most commonly
used emoji your go-to
always in circulation
um i'm you know what i'm gonna i'm gonna
have to say the heart the heart
to my wife
ah there's nothing wrong with that i
just heard i heard a lot of
listeners just doing
doing and eyeing i guess yeah i i
actually went to look
um the second one most used right now is
a birthday cake
oh okay and this one
oh the oh with the eyebrows up yeah like
oh
some not so
big yeah
in what context do you do this one that
the excited the kind of like eyebrows
why that's the keenan that's the keen
and special oh
especially
uh that was my favorite thing my
favorite thing to do with keenan in
between sketches but literally it's all
i did for nine years
whenever we're just sitting around doing
nothing and we have time i'll go uh
keenan why don't you just give me a
whoopee 39. and he like i would just
number all of his looks and like there
would be specifics like whoopi 57 is
very different from whoopi 39
and keenan would just give me give me an
email
it was the best it's my favorite numbers
he has a number for all of his reactions
he's the king of reaction
he does have a great
great face for reactions he is
great and i'm thinking of emojis in
particular like keenan doing emojis is
such a funny idea someone out there if
you're an snl fan and and i'll i will
actually send you something
if you do this
go out and find every single sketch that
doesn't have a laugh until they cut to
keenan and there's a lot of
i guarantee you there's hundreds that's
funny that's funny it's like an
immediate you just know you're gonna get
something out of it uh yeah
if you could be a professional athlete
um what sport would you hockey
oh for sure i played hockey in high
school
and oh really you were in islanders west
east chester rangers
i was a rangers fan uh if if you could
have one snack food for the rest of your
life bobby
snack food see that's funny you said
snack food and my mind said peach
schnapple but that's not really a snack
food
uh you love peach samples love it i love
it i mentioned it yeah i love it it's my
favorite tasting beverage in the world
it's very different now it's not the
same
oh i've been i was going to say i
haven't had it in years i remember the
kiwi strawberry that was usually yeah
the old go madness the old glass bottle
like seven servings of sugar per bottle
yes apple well
yeah well once i found out that that's
what it was i i used to i was
when i was younger i was under the
impression that all juice was healthy
you know yeah i knew nothing about sugar
it was just it was just water yeah yeah
it was healthy it was sweet freshly
squeezed juices
mangoes and madness um
uh
interesting peach snapples but i love it
but you're stoned if you're stoned and
you want to just yeah
um
right now i've been enjoying a little
dull whip have you had those dole whips
no pineapple i it's like pineapple ice
cream with with a little whipped cream
on top but and put like also pineapple
juice
so like wow it's almost like a like a
root beer float with pineapple ice cream
and pineapple interesting i know how
much you love movies what is it what is
a movie that i'm curious what your
favorite star wars movie is i'm curious
what you're the movie that you were
most
eager to like introduce to your daughter
you know she's for now she's getting to
the age where like she's gonna start
seeing some fun stuff um i can't wait to
show her the tv show lost but like
that's still a long time from now i feel
like yeah
uh
maybe like eight nine she would have to
be i don't know it's pretty like dark
and weird i feel like eight and nine she
might not i can't wait to watch it with
her when she's like 40.
yeah
ten years before she discovers life
issues yeah i uh i can't
yeah i can't wait till like
like those things where like she finds
mr show or like she finds party down or
like you know like like just like old
shows that i loved that she goes like
what's this like i go like yeah
that you uh some of those people have
held you honey like
isn't that funny yeah oh my god i know i
wonder if she'll be desensitized to that
i always wondered about kids with uh
parents who do do what you do like just
be like oh ted dance third teen days
after she was born
we brought her on i brought her on stage
with the muppets at the hollywood bowl
no like you know it's like it's like i
know now as like a first-time father
like what the hell was i thinking but
like i also go now like no
i have those pictures i can't wait till
she's 21 and i'm like
oh my god
yeah daddy did that daddy
what is your favorite star wars movie
i mean i think the first one probably
but like it changes all the time i i
like it's funny now i feel like i just
watch like scenes or like like like
stuff before to be honest i go back and
watch the mandalorian now whenever i
can't oh my god it's so good
and all the animated series and stuff i
like it all i'm i'm more of a fan
i think it's changing and i think now
i'm just like i'm more of a fan of like
the idea of star wars the whole you know
just the idea of like there's this thing
that some nerd created 20 years ago that
everyone's still talking about and i
really enjoy that
is that is that how you connected with
kevin smith you you
well that was that was uh i was just i
mean
i was a huge fan i i i just enjoy i love
that too like i love the idea of like a
guy from new jersey who uh helped his
buddy survive through life
and uh they created this thing together
this universe of their friends and
everybody who like they keep just coming
back and making [ __ ] like it just i i i
that's uh
that's a really cool thing i i think uh
he's an amazing dude just for doing that
alone and and i think um
the first time
i i i did kevin smith for my audition i
i did silent bob
well no i was terrible at auditions so i
i i had impressions so i the first time
i auditioned not the second time for snl
the first time i auditioned one of my
impressions was i said uh this is kevin
smith as silent bob and i had a baseball
hat with like a wig in it
like already so i just like put it on
and i just leaned against the back wall
and i smoked an entire cigarette and i
didn't say a word
you're kidding like i just thought that
was funny like i just thought that was
the bit was like that's my impression
and i literally just like i i was a
smoker at the time and i just enjoyed a
cigarette and laughed at myself and my
mind going like i can't believe i'm
doing this and like that is crazy bobby
that because you described on i think on
stern that atmosphere of that single
light being on lorne michaels out in the
audience and there's a light on you on
that iconic stage
how what what the [ __ ] do you do that
that's like
that's that was like one of the bits i
did but it was just to get out of doing
an impression and
when i i went to comic-con
and it was uh
uh jj abrams had like done this super
nice thing where he got me into that
first force awakens panel at comic-con
when it was like the entire 8-h and like
at the very end he pulled a
uh andy kaufman and he was like
everybody look under your seats
uh and everybody looked under their
seats and there was like a lanyard with
a badge in an envelope and he was like
everybody take your envelopes and your
badges and follow these guys and then
all of a sudden like a hundred
stormtroopers came in
uh came in the doors and walked down the
aisles and they opened up the side doors
and they were like
please follow these stormtroopers to the
san diego band shell where john williams
is going to play the score
of saturday night live and every all six
thousand people inside this
inside the hall
all left to go walk through san diego
and jj abrams was like come backstage
and now i'm standing there with like
harrison ford and carrie fisher and the
entire cast of star wars and everybody
and
and the producers and kathleen kennedy
and everybody and
lawrence kasdan i walked up to him and
said hi i was like what the hell's
happening and then i turn around and
kevin smith and jason muse like
and i'm sorry in my mind
jay and silent bob like i'm talking to
the cast of star wars and i too yeah and
jay and silent bob are standing in the
corner and they're both just on their
phones not saying a word to each other
like like and they're acting like
han solo isn't standing five feet away
oh and i remember being super confused
but being like oh [ __ ]
and i ran over to kevin and i was just
like a mess because i had just met all
of these people
and i was like kevin it's an honor to
meet you my name's bobby moynihan i'm on
saturday night live like a child and
just told him that i i did him and he
immediately just cut me off and was just
like
not now buddy
oh really and i was like
what
and i was a little like devastated he
just went not now like super super like
not like and i just kind of walked away
i i'll be honest i don't know if his
words were not now but he was like like
he cut it off and i i just walked away
like what the hell just happened i can
cut see that weird cut to two days later
i'm leaving comic-con
i'm getting on a plane i feel a tap on
my shoulder it's kevin smith
and he's just like i think i need to
apologize to you and i was just like
what's up man like he's like you have to
understand
we were just about to do our panel for
yoga hosers
oh and 6 000 people
just
[Music]
i know i know but and i i know but you
still it wasn't gotta give it up
it was it was an amazing moment who was
your first celebrity crush
wow maybe alyssa milano who's the boss
or kelly bundy
kelly bunny might have been like wait a
minute
yeah girls aren't yeah
um yeah yeah that isn't that funny i
think mine might have been carrying oh
yeah princess
yeah if you had to get a tattoo maybe
you have them if you had to get another
one
what would you get and where
i haven't gotten one yet i i always
wanted one a couple of the moynihan's
have one um now i always toy i was on
star wars cartoon and he had like a
little symbol on his arm and like i
always toy with getting that but i'm
like
do i really want to do that um
yeah how do you say that also to a cool
like tattoo artist what's that uh that's
my star wars character symbol
[Laughter]
as you probably may have guessed
i definitely sat in south carol south
carolina north carolina north carolina
set south carolina it was south carolina
sat down in a chair and almost got a
tattoo of a giant like a
cheeseburger right here and uh oh
yeah they were like you smell like wait
bye and i was like thank god thank god i
didn't do that oh oh they can do that
they can uh yeah they were like do you
really want this and like they kind of
asked me again and i went thank you for
your time and sheepishly walked out
you didn't commit it was like that rudy
giuliani moment yes i guess you know
what um i think we all understand what's
happening here
that's a good lack of
what is your favorite fruit bobby if you
could have any right piece of fruit uh i
want to say what is a quince just
because i never get to say is a quince a
fruit no i just wanted this i think you
say that because of rosie um
and white men can't jump what what is a
queen oh really that was what is a queen
she was on jeopardy schmidt what is a
quince i'm sorry oh sorry oh really
uh my favorite fruit [ __ ]
strawberries there's no there's no wrong
answers you still get paid
in strawberries maybe maybe strawberry
company will approach you um who would
you want to play you and your your
biopic me yeah yeah of course i know a
whole bunch of stuff who else can you do
the bobby mcgregor i would i would love
to see uh i don't know anybody
morgan freeman and like like i want to
see some stunt casting somebody
actually would probably nail it uh and
i'm so curious to ask you this because
oftentimes people are like uh-huh i
don't know i don't really know the
muppets but i know you love the muppets
um who was your favorite who was your
go-to muppet uh gonzo by leaps and bow
oh really yeah
no kidding
just uh is he one that you identified
with as a kid was there one that you
were like i'm kind of like him
yeah i just always loved
i think like i i think like gonzo has i
i think about it sometimes like when i
get mad at myself i blame gonzo for like
being weird because i go like i just
love the idea that like there was
a character that was like that they
would ask him what he was and he would
say that he was part
law he would just say like i'm part lawn
chair oh yeah he would just say things
that made no sense there was no punch
line it was just weird for weird's sake
he dated a chicken nobody knew what he
was
like he was a stunt man like
yeah that's right he shoot himself out
of cannons he was always kind of in the
way
such an odd
odd but like in his own lane kind of way
yes that's really true they really just
enjoy his demeanor
that's true in fact there's no way to
really like distill gonzo
in a sentence you know there's no way to
like
if you were to just say you know in a
sentence well who's gonzo it's it's
impossible you'd have to like
do it with what you did just like all
these little attributes like they when
in is it muppets well one of the movies
muppet movie where they're in the crates
and it says like you know he's in the
white crate frog bear
other pig and it just says whatever
whatever yeah yeah it's like that that
that that makes me that that makes me
laugh yeah totally um whatever
what is your uh
what was your daughter i mean she she
was how old i think she was maybe too
young but when she was on stage with the
muppets oh she said she excited
no she had no idea what was going on no
idea i don't even know if she could see
colors oh she was day old
you're just trying to get it into her
head during her formative yeah so so
what you do is you bring her on stage in
front of 8 000 people and hand her to
sweetums
oh my god that's the big one the big
monster right yeah yeah oh my god
uh that's amazing what was the question
again
um what's your go-to pizza topping oh uh
straight up cheese
yeah okay i'm boring
and you're in l.a are you now yes
yeah i found a couple but it's a little
cliche but it is not a great situation i
know what but if you pizza what's your
what's your what what have you found
that you like
uh all right now pepe's i don't mind if
i'm if i'm in a if i'm i'm in a pinch i
will go very quickly i know it's weird
it's like a chain but i love a thin
pizza i will go pizza aoki yeah that dj
oh no
it's good huh he makes a good thin quick
pizza oh okay that's good i didn't know
there was puppies on the west coast too
because that that's huge here i'm in
connecticut and like people always brag
you're in connecticut yeah does it can
you see where
um
oh that's right that's right because
they had a puppetry program yeah yeah
well and because they had a drama
program they also happen to have that
but yeah
and you love huskies and um
did you ever or or do you ever think you
will get do something with puppets i
mean in terms of oh gosh i hope i mean
like yeah that would be that would be
the greatest like the hosting the muppet
show
getting getting to like do sesame street
and
that was through snl like getting to do
sesame street and then meeting those
guys and nature cat is all uh
david rudman who is cookie monster and
scooter uh uh he's like a big uh sesame
street guy um as well
and kind of building that relationship
with those guys and then getting to go
to
the hollywood bowl and then the o2 in
london and like do the muppet show live
that was the oh my god
it was the the
the craziest i mean like just like yeah
i mean it's nuts it's nuts
i bet bobby um
uh
a few really quick dogs dogs or cats do
you prefer
oh dogs wait um
right oh this is a terribly long
lightning round i was gonna say no i was
gonna say i like dogs but i think i
would rather own a cat
oh interesting oh that's interesting
yeah only because they're easier to take
care of yes
yeah uh that makes sense um we said the
beatles are the rolling stones um
and if it's
whichever it is is there a song that
you'd really want to hear right now i
mean if you were in a bar if you were
anywhere with a jukebox uh i think i
would go beetles and come together but i
love the rolling stones as well but i
think i would say beetles and come
together just because that song
is great seinfeld your friends
i'll go sign film
um and ketchup or mustard i'm gonna go
catch up but i'm not a big ketchup guy
at all oh really what do you put on a
burger or any kind of vegan cheese you
don't like it wet no
no okay no ketchup i don't like ketchup
i mean like every once in a while like i
have to want ketchup i have to go like
i'm in the mood for some ketchup so i'm
gonna put some i'm gonna get some
ketchup and i'll make french fries to
have ketchup with but like
i don't i don't put ketchup on anything
ketchup is the meal for me oh wow okay
um well maybe a ketchup company will
approach you let's do it uh bobby last
question
what two adjectives do would you hope
people use to describe you after you've
um left after you've passed on um he's
back
oh
no um those aren't adjectives um no but
it i guess it counts yeah
i should have said yeah he's back
and said it positively hopefully
hopefully it's not like ah he's bad i
don't care even if they're upset to have
me back as long as i'm panicking that's
okay i just want to watch some tv i'll
leave you alone
um
i don't know had a good time
yeah something like that well well
this has been a good time um i i
bobby i i can't thank you enough i i
know you you're busy and you have the
kid there and so i really appreciate
your time such a pleasure it was a blast
[Music]
so that just happened so that i i don't
know
it's hard to an impression of someone
who does such funny characters i know
so that so that just happened i yeah
he's just affable there's an
e you know he's like he said earlier he
is so committed uh and his characters
are so specific that
to just do him is now tricky like bobby
neutral bobby's is tricky
yeah so that happened
so that happened
uh i don't know that's just like a guy
yeah i know that's just like a guy yeah
he he's got a really great laugh
such a good laugh oh my god he he
reminds me of someone a laugh that uh of
a friend of mine yes um but it's such a
great laugh you i know what you're
talking about you don't want to say it
it's so joyful yeah yeah it's all it's
like bubbly it's like there's an
effervescent and it gets like when he
really laughs a lot it becomes a little
like
maniacal you know but in like a really
joyful way
yes there's a maniacal quality to his
lap
yeah like yeah a little yeah a little
like roger rabbit you don't both have to
think that bobby my hand laughs like
roger rabbit
and he's so sharp you know he's like
yeah he's obviously all those people are
on that show just to some extent but
there's he's so quick like he knows how
to drop in a funny line yes like
whenever it's needed you know he's like
really he's really sharp yeah he's a
great um
he'd be great can you imagine him just
being like the the best guy to hang out
with
to like um to introduce to a group you
know he'd be great in a group yeah good
asset he'd be a good like socialized
asset asset what'd i say acid
acid that's how you say asset yeah acid
acid acid
acid i
never knew that about you yeah i should
maybe stop saying it or say it properly
what's that i said
it was funny when you
when you said all right i've got a quick
lightning round and
and right away he's so funny and quick
he's like oh do i win cash and i
realized that that's i can't believe no
one's ever said that before on the show
i know it was like calling a lightning
round it's such a game show
it's true what makes you think of uh
game show lightning rounds now
my horrible performance on family feud
[Laughter]
you know we have to say uh for those of
you who watch family feuds
yeah feudal feudus feudalists uh are why
do i have to make the joke better it
made it worse
that's your instinct that's my instinct
you have to examine some things i do
yeah i should look at that uh but our
friend james duffy
supporter of the show yes um and our
lives he uh
he's not our benefactor no he's
that's like great expectations
um he uh they cut like we said we they
cut a bunch of stuff out of the show but
they cut the funniest thing i think they
cut was when
they steve harvey like asked him a
question in the beginning about what he
does for a living and james was nervous
this was the first time on tv is he
gonna be mad it was his first line ever
on camera
of any sort by the way james is an
editor he's a really he's a wonderful
commercial editor and so he deals with
that world a lot he sees a lot of
performances he sees people on camera
and constantly it makes a lot of
decisions about yeah on camera but um
yeah never been on camera and um
except for this uh
mockumentary we made in college called
orgasm about a boy band but anyway not a
lot of people have seen that and until
now until now they're gonna check it out
uh and so j so steve harvey said so
james what do you do for a living and he
was thrown by the question because we
were told that you were gonna introduce
your team right all the members and
that's not what happened and all of a
sudden steve harvey's talking to you
yeah you know that's you being james yes
and so james said
[Music]
and he mumbled the word editor and steve
harvey goes in addict like with his
classic like deadpan delivery
and it was a really funny moment and
james got embarrassed and then later in
the show james's first guess was
a correct one booze
things you keep on hand uh in case a
party breaks out right in the kitchen
and then then it came back to him and
for that same category and he said
uh
drugs
and so
his three moments on that show were i'm
an addict booze and speaking of drawing
stupidly whoever edits that show cut out
the attic part that would have been such
a funny well through line maybe
that that would have been offensive
maybe they can't show that maybe i i
like i always think about that pilot i
did sober companion where they
it was doing well the network but then
they tested it with um certain
groups certain religious groups in the
uh-huh part of the country and they
didn't like it they didn't like any
anything that had to do with alcohol
um bobby moynihan yeah john conquest
speaking of drunk uncle um
so ballsy that he auditioned for snl as
a silence okay i talked to and he just
smoked a cigarette the whole time that
is i mean talk about fearlessness i know
kevin that's the first i
saw kevin smith for i did a little thing
clerks three and i saw him the day after
the end of the show friend of the show
yes uh
so on the day after i did the bobby
interview and um
and that was i said oh i just talked to
bobby whatever and you know he's a fan
of yours and and that was the first
thing kevin brought up he was like oh i
heard he did
you know silent bob and um
and and we both were like what ball like
yeah it really is like when you think
about a whole cigarette
smoking a whole cigarette
in silence with lauren michaels like
staring at you and then he told that
story about meeting kevin smith he's a
huge kevin smith fan yeah and how kevin
smith said totally yeah totally blew him
off you know he's like not now
because kevin smith was upset that all
the all the star wars people were taking
away his audience for his uh
not now and i thought i can't i can't
believe he's telling this story because
he clearly likes kevin smith and it
makes kevin smith sound terrible
but in kevin's defense
he did come back he apologized and that
to me is that's such an honorable thing
to do you know to like internalize a
mistake
and then reach out to the person that
you offended that should be celebrated
so i really should be i'm glad we're
talking about it me too yeah because
that's cool of kevin smith yes i also
love how much he loves gonzo godzilla is
such an underrated i know and it's it's
the perfect he's the perfect muppet for
bobby moynihan
i know they both are like similar energy
like random like weird and like
and and playful and like game they're
both very game i was watching so it was
weird and you think about gonzo we lose
yeah dating the chicken and he like
worked as a stunt man like he does weird
gonzo is weird well he's also always get
his body is always being abused like
he's always getting like
twisted into a pretzel or like right
also
uh fozzie's a bear miss piggy's a pig
kermit's a frog yeah what is what's
gonzo i'm like that's by me lion that's
yeah the hell is goofy yeah he is the
goofy of the muppets he is that's yeah
that's good line but both have to think
godzilla's the goofy of the muppets but
he is like no one knows what he is i
know yeah he's just like ah and that's
another thing that makes him weird and
funny is that like what is he yeah well
he's like a thing that dates a chicken
and works as a stunt man he could sort
of say that about bobby on snl like what
what was that yeah yeah oh that was that
yeah that's my point
it's hard to explain him it's hard to
pin him down yes that's true do you want
to read a letter yes okay
all right from kelly whitcomb uh subject
butt stuff oh that's so appropriate butt
stuff b-u-t-t stuff that's the subject
isn't that funny because we were
actually going to talk about our other
uncle who once
shamed
he he admonished our older brother for
using that when we were kids for using
the word but
remember that i do it was funny yeah
damian was a little kid yeah he was yeah
but but he didn't say butthole no no he
didn't say whole might have been
worthy of admonishment or like a little
kid i want you to i want to oh yeah of
course yeah damian did not say that
he just said but
okay uh hear me out uh you know what's
funny i was gonna say okay as an okay
back to the letter and here's the letter
okay hear me out
i'm throwing it back to referencing and
that's that's sorry that's a funny way
to start a letter okay hear me out yeah
yes
this is true okay hear me out like it's
almost like it's like they've been
trying to say something
and it's like all right hold on hold on
just hear me out first okay hear me out
i'm throwing it back to referencing nph
episode well you it's a deep cut yeah
it's an old the first episode it's a
classic well it's a classic it's the
first episode it's a classic to us
back to kelly um oh yeah i'm hearing her
out i thought that and other back to mph
episodes i thought that and other
episodes made my jaw drop from shock but
also informative i love how you all talk
about literally anything
we were talking about buttholes and that
how weird is that oh right do you guys
have a favorite family activity that you
would tell us listeners it sounds like
you have a good family bond and i'm
trying to get that with my current
family oh
a family activity that's a good question
um
i i also like that she thinks that it
might be slightly misleading we have a
good family i mean yeah but we don't
have a specific activity i think our
family get togethers dinners now like i
think most families
in a similar position
uh end up being
everything is about the kids yeah
because they're by far the most
entertaining part of the entire family
now yeah it's a little strange so like
the kids come over and everyone just
play like has fun with the kids yeah and
then like sometimes forgets to talk to
the other adults and sometimes when they
leave it's just like like tumbleweed
like
yeah it's like well it's just us now now
what
there's a little bit of that um dinners
were always really big in our family i
mean like
we had dinner together every night so
sometimes i hear parents say that like
kind of like they're bragging about you
know that they're making this deliberate
choice with their family like we have
dinner every night and that was always
just something i took for granted which
is a testament to i guess the good
parents that we had mm-hmm have yeah um
yeah eating eating it's like a duh but
um and now cooking like i like i started
being more curious about cooking and i
think that's a nice thing to do together
yeah bonding thing um you don't really
do that with your family no not really
but you eat with them and that i would
say that and um
like having fun with the next generation
yeah are the best activities yeah
playing
playing and eating um i mean what's
better than that
yeah well yeah
um
also not a family activity not a failure
that's okay i should have clarified uh
back to kelly also would you rather's
time great would you rather have
wow there are so many
overlapping things in this letter with
this episode really
here we go i'm going to try to say this
without laughing
would you rather have dicks be the
protein source
so you need to eat one a day
dicks v protein source v like like so
you need to have it i guess so okay or
have screws be the iron source and need
to drink a screw smoothie every day okay
let's let's unpack this um
to eat a dick so
well my first question is yeah i know
does it have to be a human dick oh i
didn't know you're gonna say that i mean
i have a lot of things because when you
say eat a dick it's not literal but in
this case it would have it is yeah you'd
have to in fact that happened when there
was a case i think in germany where a
man took an advert took a
classified ad out
for um they were looking for someone to
eat their dick like literally hmm uh it
was a fetish very
specific fetish obviously and um and i
think they did it and and the man was
i think it killed him but a guy answered
the ad and and cooked up
did it can you cook it any way you want
uh i
wonder i wonder if he was specific about
how he wanted to cook i guess whoever's
eating it it's up to that well that's my
question if it doesn't have to be a
human dick because then you get into all
issues of cannibalism stuff yeah if it
can be a different animal dick yeah and
you're allowed to cook it however you
want to cook it how would you cook it i
don't know i'd have to i'd have to think
about it i'd have to either saute it you
have to really tenderize or broil it
broil it is you get really tender meat
but it's like anything else it's it's
another part of the body so
it might be delicious
yeah um so
if it can be a non-human dick i would
100 percent do that also the screw
smoothie how do you digest is it is it
gonna cut up my insides can i blend it
so it's smooth can i put other
ingredients in the smoothie yeah or is
it just screws because then i have to
taste that metallic yeah we it needs
this needs to be moist uh kelly we
really appreciate this and i love
the theme of it i love the the
i love it all but but we need more
details on the face of it i would say i
would rather eat a dick every day
okay we'll be right back
um what if that quote is just
did you ever
think you'd say that sentence
i'd rather eat a dick every day
no
i didn't think i would i hadn't thought
about it the screw smoothie would um
how would you liquify how would you
blend right yeah we love the vitamix not
a sponsor but i love a vitamix and
that's a very powerful it is it might be
able to cut up some screws i doubt it
unless you know they make very tiny
screws have you ever seen like a very
very tiny screw you could get through
your system yeah
um well yeah i would eat a dick too
justin
wants to eat a dick
i was thinking that tmz i know and the
guy who's like just drinking out of the
cup the with a straw we should get him
on the show
christ almighty um they're like the uh
seven horsemen of the apocalypse
um
what circle of dante's hell would they
be oh yeah that's a good question um
is is gossip is he specific is dante
specifically about like gossip mongering
or that's not one of them it's not right
no what was the top one what was the
highest circle was the traitor uh that
was the lowest lowest in the ninth i
think yeah true number one traders like
it was just like uh lust i think oh boy
which is like you know every teenager is
going to hell right
back to kelly she says love you guys
kelly whitcomb
thanks kelly for um making me imagine
eating a penis
yeah i think i'm really for making me
allowing me to hear you say that out
loud and very definitively that you
would rather eat a dick and if you guys
would like to write in it doesn't have
to be as spicy it doesn't have to be a
and by the way it could be from
relatives it could be from dick
uncle dick wants to write in
our email address is life is short at
wondery.com and we'd like to thank our
very special very kind very funny guest
bobby moynihan yes bobby uh thank you
and
i'm so glad also bobby thanks for like
are you taking off your shoes now uh my
plunking them on the floor my foot is
falling asleep oh oh oh my right seems
like such an odd time to do that sorry
i'm like mr rock i'm like you're nothing
like mr rogers
no that's not true i mean it's that's so
mean
i'm saying right now i know i know well
i am i'm taking off my shoes uh anyway
i hope um i hope you guys all enjoyed
this sorry interrupt you're saying
something nice about bobby what a great
dad he must be i imagine is there a more
fun dad you can imagine i know and that
killed me too that his daughter was like
doesn't want him to do the different
voices oh that's funny he commits to he
just does one that would kill me if like
my kid was like ah it bothers me when
you do different characters that would
be tough that'd be a tough pill for you
i would be
yeah anyway um anyway see you next week
everyone yeah thanks for listening
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it is co-hosted by you christian
long also produced by you and it's
produced by megan v monaco his senior
producer is michelle miesh lance and a
uh filling in producer is katie allen
and the audio engineer on this one is
sergio enriquez executive producer is
marshall louie for a company called
wondering wondering hi everyone
[Music]
well that was dark
i thought they just need love
such a funny alternate ending to
american dude
chris cooper and kevin spacey just had
like a crazy sex scene and then the
crowds are off
that's funny for your stand-up bet
yeah i guess
it's more it's
i don't i'm not feeling it like it's my
joke though
it's funnier for you
because i didn't know chris cooper was
that's true
no
sorry
i'm gonna pitch it to justin okay
you